FOR THIRTY JANUARY NIGHT-
TWENTY TWENTY IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING
PLEASE PROCEED. AND HAS ALSO
BEEN TELEVISED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE
FOR A REASON THERE
KAMLAGER-DOVE. MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS WORKS OVER HERE RAMOS
RIVAS WICKS HERE DEEP WE HAVE A
FORM I WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA SO
MOVED SECOND OKAY. VERY GOOD.
MOVE MY MISTER MATHIS INTO
SECOND OF THAT- MYSTERY WAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AWAY AYE COOLEY AYE CARILLO I
CARILLO AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I CAN LONGER I
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE QUIRK
SILVA HI FOR EXAMPLE I RAMOS
RAMOS I REASONS. RIVAS AYE
WORKS HI WICKS ID. THE MOTIONS
PASS AND THIS RULES COMMISSION
JR